[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه
تتخللها ثلاث قمم سعوديه صينيه وصينيه
خليجيه وصينيه عربيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي يدرس احتماله خفض سعر
الغاز الروسيه رغم تحذيرات موسكو من خطوره
الخطوه
والاحتجاجات في ايران تتحول الى اضرابات
والمتاجر تغلق ابوابها في اكثر من 50
مدينه ايرانيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه وصل
الرئيس الى الرياض في زياره رسميه الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بدعوه من خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود
وكان في استقبال الرئيس الصيني في مطار
الملك خالد الدولي امير منطقه الرياض
الامير فيصل بن بندر بن عبد العزيز ووزير
الخارجيه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
وستعقدوا قمه سعوديه صينيه واخرى خليجيه
صينيه
وثالثه عربيه صينيه
كما سيلتقي العاهل السعودي والرئيس الصيني
في محادثات رسميه تتناول العلاقات
الثنائيه
والشراكه الاستراتيجيه التي تجمع البلد
[موسيقى]
وانتقل بكم مباشره الى فيديوهاتنا في
الرياض ومزيد من المتابعه حول زياره
الرئيس الصيني سجن بينج الى السعوديه مع
الزميل نايف الاحمري نايف اهلا وسهلا بك
تفضل
شكرا طالب مساء الخير مشاهدينا مستمرون
معكم في هذه التغطيه الخاصه والتي تنفرد
بها العربيه لتغطيه قمم الرياضه القمه
الصينيه السعوديه الخليجيه العربيه الرئيس
الصيني فيجن وصل الى الرياض قبل قليل في
هذه الزياره التي تاتي بدعوه من العائله
السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز لعقد
هذه القيمه قمم همم الرياضه الكثير من
الملفات السياسيه الاقتصاديه ايضا
التجاريه في العلاقات ما بين الصين وكذلك
الدول العربيه ستكون حاضره في هذه
القمم سيتم نقاشها ايضا توسيع وتوطيد
العلاقات
التجاريه بتعميقها ايضا كذلك هي من احد
الملفات وعلى راس هذه الملفات التي سيتم
نقاشها كذلك من المتوقع اتفاقيه ايضا حتى
ثنائيه بين البلديه بين السعوديه وكذلك
الصين في هذه همم الزياره وفي هذه القمم
التي تحتضنها العاصمه السعوديه الرياض ومن
العاصمه الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه اذا وصل
الرئيس الصيني قبل قليل كيف يبدو المشهد
والاجواء ايضا لديكم الذي رصدته حتى الان
عبد المحسن
عبد المحسن كنت تسمعني طيب يبدو اننا
نواجه همم عقبه يعني فنيه مع زميل عبد
المحسن الحربي وسنعود مره اخرى اليه على
جاهزه هذا الاتصال اذا مشاهدينا في همم
ابريل او نعود الى زميل عبد المحسن الحربي
يبدو انه جاهز عبد المحسن مرحبا بك معي في
هذه انفذه الخاصه التي نتابع منها هذه
الزياره الرئيس الرئيس
ما الذي دراسته حتى الان الرئيس الصيني
وصل الى الرياض قبل قليل كيف يبدو المشهد
لديك
نعم ذايب بالفعل وصل الرئيس الصيني يشيل
جنبي الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض في مطار
الملك خالد الدولي حيث كان استقبال امير
منطقه الرياض الامير فيصل بن بندر حيث تم
استقباله استقبال الرسميا وبثمان سينتقل
للرئيس الصيني الى همم قصر اليمامه ليلتقي
ااا
بالعهد السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
وولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان بعد ذلك
سيستعد جميع الجلسات الملاحظات الرسميه
يوم غدا التي من خلالها سيتم توقيع عدد من
الاتفاقيات وايضا التوقيع الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه السعوديه الصينيه المرتقبه
التي سيتم الاعلان عن تفاصيلها يوم غدا في
همم القمه السعوديه الصينيه حيث سيكون يوم
غدا هو يوم سعودي صيني خالص في ظل هذه
القمم التي ستعقد في العاصمه السعوديه
خلال همم ايام او اليومين المقبلين حيث
سيتم عقد قمه خليجيه خليجيه بالاضافه الى
خليجيه الصينيه وهي الاولى من نوعها على
مستوى العلاقات البينيه بين والخليج
والصين بالاضافه الى القمه الاخرى وهي قمه
القمه العربيه الصينيه التي قالت عنها
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه بانها نقطه تحول
في تاريخ العلاقات بين الدول العربيه
والصين بالاضافه الى ان وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه قالت بان علاقات السعوديه همم
ستكون استراتيجيه بعد هذه الزياره ايضا
سيتم تعزيز العلاقات بين الجانبين
بالاضافه الى القمم الاخرى اذا متوقع ان
تتم اليوم يتم الاستقبال الرسمي في قصر
اليمامه بعد ذلك سيتم عقد جلسه جلسات
الملاحظات الرسميه يوم غدا في اليوم الذي
يتزامل في وصول اكثر همم ما يقال في 30
قائدا واميرا وهمم ممثلا ل- اا الدول
العربيه المشاركه ايضا هنالك دول من خارج
منظومه الدول العربيه والخليجيه مشاركه في
هذه القمه نتحدث عن كمبوديا واندونيسيا
وباكستان بالاضافه الى السينغال من همم
افريقيا
فالى انه تم الاعلان عن ايضا مشاركه
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتريس في هذه الاجتماعات المرتقبه في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض اذا نايف ترقب
كبير ايضا كان هنالك وصول للوفد الصيني
يوم الامس وفد اعلامي صيني كبير جدا قادمه
لتغطيه هذه الزياره وهذه القمم التي
متوقعه ان ينتج عنها همم اتفاقيات بين
كافه الاطراف المجتمعه سواء كان همم على
مستوى العلاقات الثنائيه بين السعوديه
والصين او حتى على مستوى العلاقات
الخليجيه الصينيه وحتى على مستوى العلاقات
العربيه الصينيه ضعيف
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات كل
هذه التفاصيل التي رصدتها لنا من العاصمه
السعوديه الرياضه التي تستضيف هذه
القمم الثلاث مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن
الحربي شكرا جزيلا لك نتابعه لكم مشاهدينا
الكرام هذه الصور
الاوليه لوصول الرئيس الصيني الشجن الى
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض اذن هذه ربما
مراسم
الاحتفاء طبعا بقدومه الى العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض نتابع ايضا استقبال امير
الرياض الامير فيصل بن بندر للرئيس الصيني
همم
الذي وصل قبل قليل الى العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض في زياره رسميه تمتد
لثلاثه ايام كما ذكرنا سيعقد فيها ثلاث
قمم مهمه سعوديه صينيه وعربيه صينيه
وتسبقه ايضا الق الخليجيه همم الصينيه اذا
همم وصل الرئيس شيء جنبيك هذا الفيديو
نتابعه معكم على شاشه بينج بعد ان وصل الى
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض كما ذكرنا في هذه
الزياره الرسميه التي تمتد لمده ثلاثه
ايام من السابع حتى التاسع من ديسمبر
بدعوه من العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز سيشارك الرئيس الصيني في قمه
السعوديه صينيه همم سيشارك ايضا همم في
القمه الخليجيه والقمه العربيه مباحثات
سعوديه صينيه ستكون يوم غدا همم في هذه
القمه السعوديه الصينيه مع الاهلي
السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء الامير محمد
ابن سلمان في انتظار ما ستتمخض عنه وما
يرشح طبعا عن هذه المباحثات عن هذه همم
القمم اذا مشاهدينا الكرام وفي متابعه
لهذه الزياره
اا في ابريل عام 2021 كشف ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان ان السعوديه
تصنع شركات استراتيجيه للحفاظ على مصالحها
تعمل ايضا على تعزيز تحالفاتها مع شركائها
في العالم متابع احنا نعمل مع العالم كله
العالم كله
تحدي الامريكيه كانت في الخمسينات تشكل
50% من اقتصاد العالم اليوم حجم اقتصاد
الامريكي شك كما يقارب 20% من حجم
الاقتصاد العالمي وبداء العالم يستعيد
توازنه بعد الحرب العالميه الاولى
والثانيه نعمل على الحفاظ على شركات
الاستراتيجيه مع شركائنا في المنطقه واللي
هم اهم شركاء لنا ابتداء بدول خليج ودول
العربيه ودول الشرق الاوسط كما ان نعمل
تعزيز التحالفاتنا مع
شركائنا في انحاء العالميه بريطانيا فرنسا
اوروبا وغيرها من الدول كذلك نعمل على صنع
شركات جديده مع الجميع روسيا او الهند
الهند او الصين او امريكا اللاتينيه او
افريقيا او غيرها لمصلحه المملكه السعوديه
بما لا يضر اي دوله همم اخرى في العالم
فاليوم الصين اعلنت ايضا المملكه السعوديه
شريك استراتيجي والهند كذلك استراتيجي
وكذلك روسي
شريفيه ليلتحده الامريكيه اعز مصالحنا مع
الجميع بما يخدمنا وبما يخدم هم بما
يخدموا المصالح الدوليه وفي الاخير كل
دوله لها الخيار ان استطاع يعني نعمل معهم
على انجاز ما فيه خير للجميع كان بها ولا
نصف همم في الخيارات واسعه بالعالم
ومعي هنا في استديو العربيه المصاحب لهذه
القمم وفي المركز الاعلاميه الصحه في
الصين الهام علي سيد الهام مرحبا بك معي
في هذه التغطيه الخاصه ايضا وصل الرئيس
الصيني شيجن الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
ما الذي تبحث عن بكين في هذه الزياره وفي
هذه القمه كذلك
شكرا جزيلا
للمشاهدين الكرام وفي الحقيقه هذه القمه
او هذه الكلمه يعني تتمتعه بهانيه جدا انا
من شهود العيان لزيارتها فخامه الرئيس
الصيني السابقه يعني في عام 2016 كان من
الممكن ان نقول هناك نقطه تحول العلاقات
الصينيه العربيه بشكل خاص الصينيه
السعوديه وبعد همم سته سنوات واكثر من ست
سنوات في الحقيقه همم الان مع تتطور سريع
على العلاقات الثنائيه بين
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه وبين الصين
ودول العربيه بشكل عام يعني الان حان
الوقت لهذه القمم التاريخيه ففي الحقيقه
يعني هذه القمم تاريخيه اول شيء يعني جاء
همم وقت مهم جدا وخصوصا يعني نعرف اول شيء
هذه زياره جاء لي يعني المملكه ال- همم
الدوله الاولى لزياره فقمه الرئيس الصيني
من من ضمن همم طول الشرق الاوسط بعد
المؤتمر الوطني العشرين يعني احس بشعي
صيني وبعد اعاده انتخابات الرئيس الصيني
سجن كال الامين نعم او قياده الحزب
وبالاضافه الى ذلك يعني نعرف قبل عده ايام
يعني للاسف شديده هناك همم يعني همم الخبر
ما اسوي للشعب الصيني و
الرحيل رئيس الاسبق الصيني وبذلك يعني بعد
الجنازه رسميا بيوم واحد فقط يعني غادر
فخامه الرئيس الصيني ومتوجه الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ويعني هذا يعكس عدم
تغيير الموعد لزياره هذه ايضا يعكس على
اهتمام بجانب الصيني نعم فكرت نقطه تحول
حدثت بعد زياره سجن بنك الى السعوديه في
عام 2016 التي اتت كذلك ايضا بدعوه من
العائله السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز جرى فيها توقيع العديد من
الاتفاقيات ايضا بين البلدين ما هي نقطه
التحول التي
تم وضعها في هذه الزياره وتطورت بعد ذلك
العلاقات السعوديه واصبحت همم طريقه في
همم مسارها السياسيه الاقتصادي والتجاري
كذلك يعني من ذلك من تلك الذي تم تاسيس
العلاقات الاستراتيجيه الشامله لشرعك بين
البلدين وهذه النقطه مهمه جدا لان يعني
هناك دول محدوده بين مع الصين لهذه النوع
من العلاقات ونعرف ان هناك علاقات قويه
جدا بين صيني والعروسي ولكن
بعد هذا المستوى يعني مستوى العلاقات
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله وبالاضافه
الى ذلك يعني همم كان الرئيس الصيني وخادم
الحرمين الشريفين شهدت عدد من
المشاريع في تدسين خلال زياره في عام 2016
وخصوصا لحسن ان هناك همم مراسم تدرس
من صفات ينبع يصرف في
مشاركه مع شركه سينما شركه شركه السعوديه
وبالاضافه الى ذلك يعني زي ما فضلت مع
زياره خادم الحرمين الشريفين الى الصين
وايضا زي ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان الى الصين يعني هناك
نقطه مهمه جدا مهما كانت من الجانب
الاقتصادي وتجاري وايضا من الجانب الثقافي
والانسانيه الحقيقه يعني نعرف ان هناك
مبادره يعني مهمه جدا من الجانب الصيني
مبادره حزام طريقه وايضا من الجانب
السعودي رؤيه ليله 30 ومن ضمنها يعني هناك
نقطه ترعبت يعني
المعروف عنها انها بلد اقتصاديا بشكل كبير
تركز على التجاره تركز على التعاملات
الاقتصاديه مع الدول في اساسها الاول وحتى
علاقتها مع السعوديه بدات يعني منذ 80
عاما بشكل تجاري لم تتطور بشكل دبلوماسي
همم وبشكل الرسمي الا في بدايه التسعينات
لاي مدى الصين تنظر اليوم الى ان هناك
اهميه بالغه فيما يخص الاقتصاد والتجاره
السعوديه ولي الخليج ايضا كذلك كيف تنظري
بهذا بك نعم او شيء يعني لازم ان اشير الى
ان هناك اهميه بالغه للمصالح المشتركه
تجاريا والاقتصاديه ولكن في نفس الوقت مع
تطور الاوضاع العالميه في السنوات الاخيره
وخصوصا نعرف هناك مواجهات بشكل مباشر بين
الدولتين العملاقتين بين الصين والولايات
المتحده لذلك الان يعني هناك اتجاهات
جديده من كل دول العالم مهما كانت من جانب
الصيني وايضا من الدول العربيه وبما فيها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه فلفل حقيقه يعني
ما ترحم فخامه الرئيس الصيني لمبادره
الامن العالمي في العام الماضي هناك ردود
فعل ايجابيه جدا من قبل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وايضا يعني كما لحسنا في زياره صاحب السمو
الاميره فيصل بن فرحان في بدايه العام
الجاري هناك يعني
ال- ال- الاهتمام مشتركه من قبل الجانبين
للحفاظ على الانستغرام والسلامه في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط او خصوصا يعني نعرف الشرق
الاوسط الان وما زالت تواجهه تحديات امنيه
وال- همم السياسيه لذلك يعني الصين لديها
مبادرات وايضا لديها جهود مستمره
وبالاضافه الى ذلك من الجانب السعوديه
هناك اهتمام ايضا بذلك لذلك يعني هناك
ترابط او نقول النقاط المشتركه بين
الجانبين ولذلك يختار الصين وايضا المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هذا توقيت
القمه الثلاثه المهمه ايضا هناك يعني سؤال
مهم ربما ايضا حتى اطرحه ضيفه الدكتور عبد
العزيز الصقر في نشرتنا السابقه كنا نسال
عن الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين الصين وايران
وكذلك الان الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين
الصين السعوديه وكذلك في همم الطريق دول
الخليج ايضا وربما سيت شيء اخر في القمه
العربيه لا نعلم حتى هذه اللحظه ولكننا
نقرا يعني ما يمكن ان ان يحدث الصين كيف
تستطيع ان تحدث توازنا في هذا الملف هل
تفهم القلق قلقتم الخليج ربما من
التهديدات الايرانيه التدخلات كذلك ايضا
حتى في شؤونها الداخليه والتغذيه الاذرع
الايرانياتها في المنطقه لاي مدى بكين
تدرك هذا الخطر بالنسبه لشركائها في
المنطقه نعم اول شيء يعني من تصريحاتها من
قبل وزاره الخارجيه سينيه الاجابه واضحه
الصين تتفهم بكل
شارك الاوسط ان احنا كان من من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه او من دول اخرى وفي
الاجانب اخر يعني الصين يعني تتمسك بمبدا
عدم تشكيل حلفاء او تحالف ما احنا كان
عسكريه عصريه حتى العلاقات الصينيه
الروسيه من الجانب الصيني همم الحكومه
الصينيه لا تعتبر العلاقات بين هو روسيا
يعني علاقه التحالف بس همم لان الجانب
الصيني على العلاقاتها الشرعركات لذلك
يعني بثاني شيء بنسبه الى
التوازن ما يسمى بتوازن من جانب الصيني في
الشرق الاوسط في الحقيقه زي ما ذكر صاحب
سمو الامير فيصل بن فرحان يعني ليس من
لازم ان نختار جانب من الجانبين او جانب
من الجوانب ولكن يعني لدينا مصالح مشتركه
ولدينا اهتمامات المشتركه اعتقد يعني من
جانب الدول الشرق الاوسط يعني اهتمام
مشتركه ايضا لتحقيقه للسلام والاستقرار
لذلك في حاجه لبدل جهود المشتركه
بين دول الشرق الاوسط او من دوله خارج هذه
المنتدى لتحقيق ذلك
الغربي في العلاقه مع الصين ربما وضع له
خلال الازمه الماضيه بين خلال الازمه
الحالي عفوا بين روسيا واوكرانيا وضعت له
همم مثلا رئيس الوزراء البريطاني قال بان
شهر العسل قد انتهى مع بكي بالتالي نحن
نسال هنا هذا التعاطي هذا المعيار الذي
وضعه الغرب هل يدفع شيشه بنج لتعميقي
علاقاته مع شركاه في الشرق الاوسط او ربما
تقويتها باكثر والدفع باتجاهات ربما ابعد
من الاقتصاد اتجاه التجاره نعم مثل
الحقيقه يعني شهر العسل اكيد ينتهي لانها
شهر واحد فقط ولكن العلاقات الصداقه يستمر
الى الابد مهما كان من بين الصين والدول
العربيه او بين الصين الدول الاوروبيه
فيعني ال- همم الاجابه واضحه جدا مع
ازمهرون ايضا مع ازمه همم الاوكرانيه ما
زال الحجم الاستثمار من بين ال ال شركه
الاوروبيه الى الصين تزداد بشكل مستمر
وبالاضافه الى ذلك يعني الصين
يتعاون معاشات
مع مع شده دول اعلى بما فيها دول اوروبيه
وبما فيها دول العربيه ففي الحقيقه نعم ان
هناك رقمين مهم جدا او شيء يعني المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشريكه تجاري الاول من
دول العربيه للصين في ذلك يعني
العدد يتجاوز 80 مليار دولار امريكي في
عام الماضي بالاضافه الى ذلك يعني هناك
تكامل طبيعي من بين الصين ودول العربيه
بالاضافه الى ذلك يعني لا نهتم ببعضها
تصريحات همم حتى نقول ممكن هناك بعد اعمال
من بين ال همم
دوله عربيه من بينها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في السنوات الاخيره يعني الحقائق
المعروف ولذلك يعني هناك كالحاجه ماسه
الجهود المشتركه بين صيني والمملكه
العربيه وايضا عدو العربيه الاخرى لمواجهه
هذه التحديات لا نقول
اعمال العداء ولكن يعني لمواجهه المشتركه
لهذه التحديات اشكرك جزيل الشكر على
مشاركتي في هذا الحوار الصحفي الصيني
الهام علي الذي شاركني في هذه النافذه
التي اطلينا عليكم منها همم طبعا في
تغطياتنا مؤكده العربيه بهذا الاستديو
الخاص في المركز الاعلامي همم التابع لقمم
همم الرياض والذي سنتابع في هذه الزياره
الرسميه للرئيس الصيني شيجن بنجلادي وصل
كما ذكرنا قبل ساعه الى العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض اللي يشارك في هذه القمم الصينيه
السعوديه الخليجيه الصينيه والعربيه همم
الصينيه اذا المشاهدين الكرام مرحله تطوير
للتماشي مع تغيرات العصر
رؤى البلدين دخلتها العلاقات السعوديه
الصينيه علما بان هذه العلاقات مبنيه على
اكثر من 70 عاما من التعاون والتنسيق
والشراكه الاستراتيجيه في كافه المجالات
نشاهد
استقبال حجاجا وتجارات بسيطه جذور بنيت
عليها العلاقات السعوديه الصينيه الممتده
منذ سبعه 77 عاما
[تصفيق]
العلاقات التي ابتسمت ببساطه اوليه اتخذت
شكلها الرسمي قبل 32 عاما بعد اتفاق
البلدين على اقامه علاقات دبلوماسيه كامله
وتبادل السفراء وتنظيم اجتماعات على
مستويات سياسيه واقتصاديه وغيرها
[تصفيق]
محطات عده تبعت هذه المرحله كتشكيل لجنه
سعوديه صينيه مشتركه عام 2004 برئاسه وزير
خارجيه البلدين والاتفاق على بدء حوارا
سياسيا منتظمه تبعها الاعلان عن اقامه
علاقات الصداقه الاستراتيجيه عام 2008
[تصفيق]
من محطاتها كذلك زيارتان للملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز اولها في عام 99 حين كان اميرا
لمنطقه الرياض اما الثانيها في عام 2014
كوليا للعهد وكانت تاكيد مجددا على
اعتزازه بمستوى العلاقات الثنائيه التي
تشمل مختلف اوجه التعاون المشتركه
[تصفيق]
وما بينها زيارات لرؤساء الصينيين للمملكه
ملفاتها مره اخرى شملت التشديد على
التعاون والتشاور والتنسيق سعيا لتعزيز
السلم والامن اقليميا ودوليا
وهنا المواقف ثابته عند ضروره ايجاد تسويه
سياسيه عاجله للمساله السوريه ووحده اليمن
وسيادته
[تصفيق]
من دوليه لقاءات لولي العهد الامير محمد
بن سلمان بالرئيس الصينيه احدها في قمه
دول مجموعه العشرين بالارجنتين عام 2018
عقبها بزياره الى بكين في العام التالي
حرص على تبادل الزيارات رفيعه المستوى غزه
ومجموعه التفاهمات بالمجلات الاقتصاديه
تذهب باتجاه المواكمه بين مبادره الحزام
والطريق ورؤيه 2030 فالسعوديه الشريك
الرئيسي للجمهوريه الشعبيه في المنطقه
اذا نعود ان نذكر مشاهدينا الكرام بان
الرئيس الصيني شيء بنك قطوه قد وصل الى
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض وكان في استقباله
امير الرياض صاحب السمو الملكي الامير
فيصل ابن بندر بن عبد العزيز لدى وصوله
الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض في هذه
الزياره الرسميه التي تستمر لمده ثلاثه
ايام انتهت تغطيتنا من هنا من هذه النافذه
عود مره اخرى الى زميل طارق
لديكم ساعات طويله انت وباقي الزملاء غدا
وبعد غدا في هذه التغطيه لهذه القمم شكرا
صحيح
نشره الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
لابروف يعتبروا ان توسع على النت ما
يزالوا الدافع الاساسيه
باسرارها العتيقه اساطير مضت منذ الاف
السنين
لكننا نعيش الان عصرا جديدا
لنسرد قصه جديده اسطوره لمكان يتجاوز صدى
الاثار
جزيره بكر في البحر الاحمر بمياهه الصافيه
[موسيقى]
تنسجم فيها الفخامه مع الطبيعه وتساهم في
حقها وكل لحظه فيها تجسد الهام جديدا
ليكشف النقابه عن عالم جديد
جزيره
ستكون فيها انت بطل قصتك
كن جزءا من الاسطوره سندريلا
[موسيقى]
تحت غيوم الجنوب وسط جبالها والله على صحن
جريش يجمعنا في نجد الاحباب
[موسيقى]
على بحر الشرقيه
من ريح الهبوب الشماليه ولبن المراعي طعام
المميز حاضر معنا فيك الجمعه الحلوه
[موسيقى]
بنيناها معكم يوم بعد يوم
بنيناها بالتربيه الصح
في مزارع بالمعايير الاصح
لجاج اليوم
[موسيقى]
مشوار
ومع هذا لسه بتعرف كيف تختار
حليب المراعي الطازج الفرق بين الامهات
[موسيقى]
الداخليه الالمانيه
في الداخل وان القانون سيطبق بحزم ضد
العناصر المتطرفه
مع المعتقلين يتم استخدامها في الجيش
الالماني
سابقه من حزب البديل الالماني ومواطنين
روس ضمن حمله الاعتقالات
العامه قد اكد ان حملات التفتيش طلب 100
تموقع على الاقل في 11 ولايه واسفرت عن
اعتقال 25 شخصا كانوا يخططون الاستهداف في
مواقع سياديه من بينها البرلمان بالتعاون
مع جماعه مسلحه
وزاره الدفاع الالمانيه اكدت ايضا تعقيبا
على اعتقال جندي خلال حمله المداهمات ضد
تيار اقصى اليمين انها لن تتسامح مع اي
عمل متطرف من داخل الجيش ومن جهه قال
متحدث باسم الحكومه الالمانيه ان
المداهمات التي وصفها بالناجحه هي دليل
على ان الدوله في حاله تاهب ضد التضطر
الكرملين وصف من جهته المداهمات الجاريه
ضد جماعات اقصى اليمين في المانيا بانها
شان داخلي ولا علاقه لروسيا به هذا ونفت
السفاره الروسيه في برلين اي ارتباط لها
مع اي جماعات ارهابيه او خارجه على
القانون او كيانات غير شرعيه في المانيا
واكدت في بيان انها لا تقيم اتصالات مع
هذه الجماعه
مزيد من المتابعه مراسله العربيه راغب
انام رغد اهلا وسهلا بك جديد حمله
المداهمات والاعتقالات وهي السابقه في
التاريخ الالماني الحديث على الاقل خصوصا
لجهه المتهمين او الحجم وهل فعلا كان
هؤلاء يريدون قل يعني الانقلاب انقلاب على
من
اهلا بك يعني هي المداهمات انتهت بدات
صباحا في الساعه السادسه فجرا ربما هو ليس
صباحا وانتهت يعني بعد ساعات من ذلك
باعتقال 25 شخص بالفعل هي اكبر عمليه يعني
يتم الكشف عنها حطيت لها همم اليمين
المتطرف في المانيا رغم انه هذه الجماعه
التي تنتمي لما يعرفون بمجموعه مواطنين
رايح الذين لا يؤمنون بالدوله الالمانيه
الجمهوريه او الفدراليه الالمانيه كما هي
الان همم وهم لا يطيعون القوانين وما الى
ذلكم لديه
التي يتنظمون من خلالها بهذا الشكل
وبالفعل التفاصيل يعني التي تخرج يعني ملف
جدا بانه هناك اعضاء الان على الاقل عضو
واحد الان يعني هذه النائبه اللي كانت
نائبه سابقه في البرلمان هي الان كانت
تشغل موقع قادم في محكمه اقليميه في برلين
لذلك هناك اشخاص لديهم داخل هذه السلطه
في مناطق كثيره هناك عدد كبير من الجنود
الالماني السابقين كما ذكرت قبل قليل واحد
منهم هو جندي حالي منهم في القوه الخاصه
ايضا يعني هؤلاء كانوا سيشكلون همم ما
ارادوها ان يكون الجناح العسكري كان كان
يخططون لاقامه جماعه عسكري هو مهمته
الاستيلاء على همم يعني او ان يبدا هذا
الانقلاب بالاستلاء على البستان همم
البرلمان الفيدرالي وبعد ذلك ان تكون هناك
حكومه يبدو انه تم التحضير اليها وهذه
القاضيه الان كان من المفترض ان تكون
وزيره العدل ورئيس يعني هي الدوله كان من
المفترض ان يكون من هو الان تقول الشرطه
والادعاء بانه رئيس هذه الخليه هو اا يعني
رجل اعمال اا من فرانكفورت هو لديه اصول
نبيله من عائله نبيله المانيه قديمه همم
يعني ما زال يحافظ على لقبه الامير رغم
انه يعني هذا اللقب بالله لا يعني لا
يستخدم الان ليس هناك ملكيه همم في
المانيا لذلك بالفعل يعني همم الان همم
ايضا هناك لانك ذكرت بانه كان هناك نفسي
من الكلام
يعني
الرابط بين الحرب في اوكرانيا وتحرك هذه
الجماعات هل يمكن الربط بشكل او باخر مع
العلم ان مصر كنافه التماما اي علاقه لها
بالفعل اولا لانه بيني معتقلين 25 كان
هناك مواطن روسي هذا المواطن الروسي بحسب
ما يقول الادعاء كان ساعد يعني رئيس هذه
الخليه المزرعه على ان يتواصل مع مسؤولين
الروس عبر اجراء اتصالات وضعه على تواصل
او محاوله تواصل مع مسؤولين في السفاره
الروسيه في برلين لان الدعاء كان واضح في
بيانه بانه ليس واضحا ما اذا كان قد حصل
على الرد من المسؤولين الروس هنا جاء يعني
ربما بيان السفاره الروسيه لين في بين
يكون هناك اي علاقه همم مع هذه المجموعه
لذلك الرابط في ج- في جزئين يعني رابط
بانه هناك محاوله للتواصل مع السفاره
الروسيه ورابط بانه هناك مواطن روسي غير
معروف الان على اي اساس كان يساعد هذه
المجموعه ما اذا كانت
يعني من موسكو مثلا او انه كان يتصرف بشكل
فردي لذلك يعني هذه النقطه الاستفهام ربما
التي ستكشف في الايام المقبله ايضا يعني
اريد ان اشاهد طالب بانه عاده الاحزاب
اليسريه المتطرفه واليمنيه المتطرفه في
المانيا هي متعاطفه مع روسيا لديها علاقات
جيده مع روسيا هناك زيارات دائما بينهم
ربما لذلك ايضا حصل هذا الرابط الفوري
دائما شكرا جزيلا لك راغده على كل هذه
المتابعه
قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه على النت
وميزال هو الدافع الاساسي للحلف مشيرا الى
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
رفضا مقترحات روسيا بشان الضمانات
الامريكيه
للامن على بروكسيل واشنطن لكننا تلاقينا
رفضا لمناقشتها وحينها قال ستالتنبرغا ان
حلفانيتو لا يستطيع ان يضمن امن دوله
خارجه هذا الحلف الذي نشا بفكر دفاع يبدو
انه تخلى عن هذا المبدا بالتوسيع عضويه
خمسه اضعاف النيته لم يعد منتشرا على ضفتي
الاطلسي فقط بل توسع الى المحيطين الهندي
يخترق مبادئ منظمه الامن والتعاون
الاوروبي ويعرقل عمل منظمه اسيا
فيديو
جدا لمزيد من المتابعه اذا ينضم اليه من
موسكو الصحفي من وكاله سبوتنيك عماد
اطفالي الاستاذ عماد اهلا وسهلا بك الى
نشاط الخامسه المعلومات المتواتره من بعض
المواقع الاعلاميه الالمانيه تتحدث عن دور
روسي محتمل في مجرى من عمليات مداهمات
واعتقالات مع العلم ان موس كنافه تماما
هذا الامر ولكن استاذ عماد مجرد ان يتم
ذكر او الحديث عن دور محتمل لموسكو ما
الذي يعني ذلك خصوصا نحن نتحدث عن عمليه
انقلاب كان يخطط لها في المانيا
اولا يعني كما حضرتك اشارت او كما جاء في
البيان بان السفاره الروسيه في المانيا او
الكريملاند يعني اعلن بشكل واضح بانه ليس
هناك اي علاقه لروسيا بهذا الامر اولا هذا
شان داخلي وثانيا يعني ليس هناك عادات
وتقاليد لسياسه الروسيه ان تتدخل بهذا
الشكل الفاظ يعني في دول اخرى يعني ربما
هذه الصفه يمكن وصفها لسياسه الامريكيه
التي يعني
تنتهجها سواء في عدد كبير من المناطق
ويعني وما يحصل اليوم هو ايضا نتيجه
للتدخل الامريكي في اكياف 2014
ودعم الانقلاب همم ضد الرئيس
الشرعيش يعني عمليه روسيا لا يمكن لها ولا
للسياحه الروسيه يعني تحترم دائما كل
الدول وعلاقات ها على الرغم من ان هناك
يعني توتر حاليا في العلاقات مع المانيا
لكن ليس من شيه معاهدات وتقاليد وتوابت
السياسه سواء الخارجيه او الداخليه
الروسيه ان تتدخل بهذا الشكل ابدا في
موضوع متصل سمعت الى السيد سيرجي لبروف ما
يقوله لا ما زالف
يواصل سياسته في التوسع همم على حدود
روسيا واخروا نشر منظومات وبطاريات صواريخ
باتريوت او القرار بالموافقه على اشرف
بتاعه الاميركيه همم في بولندا اولا ما
الذي يعنيه ذلك وكيف سترد موسكو في حاله
تم نشر هذه البطاريات همم باتريوت بولندا
في ما يخص بولندا يعني ربما هي ااا يتم
نشرها لكن
هناك تصريح روسي لنائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي اعلام انه في حال وصول هذه
المنظمات الصواريخ الباتريوت الى اوكرانيا
يعني طبعا ستكون هدف للقوات الروسيه
باعتبارها ايضا همم خط احمر لماذا لانه
هذه المنظمات باتريات يعني انا لست خبيرا
عسكريا لكن اعرف جيده بانه يمكن استخدامها
ليس فقط للدفاع الجوي وانما ايضا يمكن همم
تجهيزها بصواريخ بعيده المدى صواريخ
هجوميه يمكن ان يعني تطال العمق الروسي
وهذا يشكل تهديد للامن القومي الروسي وهذا
خط احمر وهناك يعني تحديد واضح يعني ربما
تنشر في فنلندا وهناك تجري مشاورات بين
المانيا وبولندا بهذا ان هناك موافقه
المانيه على ان تنشر فقط في بولندا لكن طب
رافت نشر هذه
المنظمات في اوكرانيا
كما قلت يعني تعتبر خط احمر بالنسبه
طيب من موسكو الصحفي من وكاله سبوتنيك
عماد الطفيلي شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ عماد
على هذه المشاركه
هذا وتدرس دول الاتحاد الاوروبي سعر الغاز
الطبيعي بعد ايامنا على تطبيق قرار اوروبي
حدد سقفا لسعر البرميل من النفط الروسيه
عند 60 دولار وقال موقع ايرو اكتيف
البلجيكي ان الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي تدرس
احتمال خفضي حد سعر الغاز الى 220 يورو
لكل ميغاوات ساعه
وكان رئيس روسي نادي ليفربول قد حذر في
اكتوبر الماضي من تحديد السقف لاسعار
الغاز مشيرا الى ان ذلك سيكبر اوروبا
خسائر بميئات المليارات
نشاط الخامسه مستمره في ايضا
الاحتجاجات في ايران تتحول الى اضرابات
والمتاجر تغلق ابوابها في اكثر من 50
مدينه ايران
[موسيقى]
لا تتنازل ولا ترضى بشيء عادي لكن المراعي
اجود زبادي مع زبادي المراعي كالاكل الف
من هنا انت على موعد مع العالم عالم واحد
صوت واحد هدف واحد بطولات العالم كل ما
يجري حول الساحره المستدير
بالعالم
العربيه
منتصف الليل على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يلا نبي نصحصح النبي الاكل ابداع جهزي
العده وافردي الخبزه وادهن اللبنه ايه
والحين وين العجينه حطي اللبنه والزعتر
رشيه ايوه بالضبط اغر فيها شويه سمان الله
والخيار قطعيه ايوه غمسيه يا سلام عليك يا
فنانه
كل فخر صنعت في السعوديه لبنه المراعي
الفاخره طعمها يبيض الوجه
في ايران تغلق محالها التجاريه في احد
اكبر الاضطرابات العامه منذ عقود تشهدها
ايران
مع الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في الشوارع
الايرانيه والممتده منذ سبتمبر الماضي حسب
الصحيفه
[تصفيق]
من هذه الاصدقاء الضيقه في اسواق طهران
فلا بقاله ولا جزار ولا حتى صيدليه الا
وحرصت على المشاركه بتنفيذ قرار بدا شعبي
هذا المشهد وتكرر في اكثر من 50 مدينه
ايرانيه اغلق تجارها ابواب محالهم ولا
بونداء دعوات المنسقه للاضراب لمده ثلاثه
ايام
الايرانيون الذين انتقلوا من الاحتجاج
ليلا من اسطح منزلهم خوفا من قمع الحرس
الثوري يضربون في وضع النهار ويعلنون
مواقفهم بمشاركه واسعه من الطبقه العامله
من كل الفئات
جعبه النظام من التهديد واساليب القمع
التي لجا اليها لاخافه الايرانيين يبدو
انها خلت فمن قتل الميداني واحكام الاعدام
الصادره عن قضاء النظام والسجن والسحلب
بالاضافه الى التحرش باطفال باغتصاب
لفتيات كلها اعمال كشف عنها نشطاء ومراكز
حقوقيه تحت عنوان جرائم ارتكبها النظام
ونددت بها مؤسسات حقوقيه دوليه ومحليه
والان يهدد النظام الغاء التراخيص
التجاريه واعتقالي اصحابها
احتجاجات الايرانيين ضد نظام طهران تختلف
عن سابقاتها هذه المره فهي الاطوال زمنا
كما تتميز بتحد يوصف بالكبير ورغم توقعات
خبراء ان تلك تظاهرات لن تسقط النظام
الحليب لانها تشكل هزه كبيره بحقه تنازلات
ابدا نظام مرغما على تقديمها في محاوله
الاحتواء الوضع الداخلي لكن الشارع يصفها
بتنازلات مخادعه
حنان المصري العربيه
اهلا وسهلا بك ما زالت المعلومات متضاربه
من ايران حول ما اذا كانت السلطات قد جمدت
فعلا عمل شرطه الاخلاق كخطوه اولى في طريق
حضنها ايه ما هي معلوماتك اولا والى ان
ماذا تعتقد ان هذا الامر لو تم في حال تم
سيكون كفيلا بامتصاص حده التظاهرات ام لا
الاحتجاجات اصبحت في مكان اخر تخطط مساله
مقتل امين
تحيه طيبه لك والمشاهديه العربيه الكرام
الواقع كما تفضلت المعلومات في بخصوص شرطه
الاداب او شرطه الاخلاق لا تزال متضاربه
لكنما لارجح بان هذه الخطوه سيتخذها
النظام بالتالي لانها امم ربما يستطيع
النظام من خلالها ان يبرئ ساحه المرشد
الايراني لان من اسس شرطه الاخلاق هي
المجلس الاعلى للثوره الثقافيه والمسؤول
عنها خامني لذلك في ظل وجود همم لجنه
التخصص حقائق دوليه ممكن ان توجه بعض
التهامي مباشره الى خامني لذلك هذه احدى
الخيارات التي ربما يتخذها النظام
الايراني امام مدى جدوى هذه الخطوه
بامتصاص الغضبان اعتقد بانها سوف تزيد من
الغضب الجماهيري لان هذا الحراك الثوري لم
يخرج لكي يبلغ شرطه الاداب او شرطه
الاخلاق او ربما مساله الحجاب هي الا
مساله جانبيه من بنك اهداف هذا الحراك
الثوري الغائم في ايران ولكن الم تنزع من
يد المحتجين حجما
انا اعتقد بان هذا الامر وهو ليس اصل ليس
ضمن شعراء المحتجين
ولم يخرجوا اساسا فيما يتعلق حتى مقتل
مساعميني مساء ميني كانت جزء من حركه
احتجاجيه شهدناها كل شهرين او ثلاثه اشهر
في ايران خلال خمس سنوات الماضيه هنالك
عده قضايا بنيويه يعارضها النظام والكل
يوجه سهامه الى المرشد الايراني باعتباره
هو المسؤول عن هذه
النزعه الديكتاتوريه والنظام الايراني
يعني حتى التيار مثلا داخلي في رساله همم
محمد خاتم التي نشرت على الصحافه
الاصلاحيه على الاقل همم مباشره اشار بان
على النظام ان يراجع همم كثير من سياساته
وكثير من القوانين التي همم تؤسس الى
الديكتاتوريه داخل داخل هذا النظام
واهممها مجلس صيانه الدستور الذي يتحكم من
خلاله المرشد الاي ويعزز همم سلطه على كل
همم يعني اجهزه الدوله وسلطات في ايران بس
اذا عارف مع ذلك ان تقرر السلطات في ايران
دراسه حضر هذه همم يعني شرطه الاخلاق شرطه
الحجاب سميها ما شيء الا يعني ذلك ان
المعارضه حققت مكسبا او ربحت بالنقاط
لنقل حتى الساعه في هذه المعركه
في ما يبدو يعني المغاربه التي يعتمد
عليها النظام هي ان يغلل هذا الحراك
الثوري ويحوله الى
احتجاجات مطلبيه بمعنى هنالك مطالب ويتم
التجاوب معها انا اعتقد ان العقليه التي
تحرك هذه الاحتجاجات ليست احتجاجات ما
تطلبيه هنالك بنك اهداف لحراك ثوري هذه
العقليه هي التي تحرك الاحتجاجات ثواب
داخل او الخارج وكل الذين يذهبون همم
ويخرجون بهذه الاحتجاجات يذهبون بهذا
المنحى
مثال سريعا همم يعني اذا ما شاهدنا مثل
الاضرابات العامه نحن الان نشهد اضرابات
ذات وجهين الوجه الاول يتعلق باصحاب
المحال بمعنى انهم ساند وهذا الاحتجاجات
اما الوجه الثاني وهو وهو المهم هو احجام
المجتمع من الذهاب الى الشراء من ال- من
المحلات التجاريه وهذا يدل على شيء يدل
بان الشعب سواء همم من خلال اصحاب المحل
التجاريه او الشعب باعتباره هو الذي يقبل
الى الشرى من هذه المحلات كلاهما همم ومن
همم
من لندن عارف ناصر البحث في الشال
الايراني شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
نشره الخامسه المفصله انتهت وفينكم بها من
قناه العربيه اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]